I work for clever health my name is
Christopher Hartfield and today we're
gonna talk a little bit about the clover
transform framework so this is something
that clover developed over about a year
and it's something that we use to kind
of democratize data at clover health so
before I start I'll kind of give a quick
introduction of what clever health is
clover health is an entirely new
approach to health care so we are a
health insurance company we have markets
in New Jersey Pennsylvania Texas and
Georgia a little bit about us is we're a
Medicare Advantage insurance company so
when you turn 65 in the United States
you have the option of either going into
just traditional Medicare where the
government pays your bills or you can go
into Medicare Advantage where the
government pays a private company to
basically run health insurance for you
clover is one of those companies so
we're a Medicare Advantage insurance
company so we pay claims and do health
care insurance for people who are over
65 so these are for seniors we're
headquartered in San Francisco we have
quite a large tech team here with about
50 engineers and play an equal number of
data scientists as well and we're
venture backed by Sequoia Wildcat and
first-round so a little bit about what
we try to do a little bit differently
than other insurance companies here in
America if clover really believes that
data is what can make people healthier
and really drive down insurance costs so
we we take a lot of the data that we
receive from all of our different
patients through all of our different
interactions with the patient's we take
the data we put it through a variety of
pipelines we process it and we look to
find unique trends in that data where
you know we try to predict diseases or
we try to predict where people might
become ill or where they might be at
risk for something and we take that and
then we drive interventions based on
that so we're really about using data to
drive better health care so a little bit
about how clever tries to do this is
that we we bring a lot of data into
clover
most people probably don't realize that
your health insurance company it pretty
much has
the bulk of healthcare data out there
about you so anytime you go to a
doctor's office a whole bunch of data
gets sent to your health insurance
company you are hospitalized you have a
surgery you have a lab done all of that
data is going to a health care company
are your health insurance company so
clover receives an enormous amount of
data multiple most health insurance
companies is very siloed data that they
receive for like utilization management
that's whether to approve or deny
procedures that just kind of sits in one
database information from a claims from
claims that's it's in another database
appeals that's another database and so
really in a lot of health insurance
companies data is extremely siloed and
data is only connected by people and
that's a real problem because it takes
people looking at it or doing it in
Excel to really connect the data clover
sees things a little bit differently we
would like to actually and we do put all
of our data into central data warehouses
and then from there we can derive better
analytics and we can have systems and
processes that automatically predict
diseases or you know potentially
life-threatening healthcare events for
our members so when you think about this
there's a large amount of data coming
into our insurance company so one of the
kind of oh sorry one of the kind of
buzzwords out there is a data lake and
it's the idea that you kind of put all
this data that you have and all of its
different formats into a kind of a
central spot and a lot of people use
like s3 or maybe Postgres in some form
for doing data lakes and and that makes
a lot of sense for a health insurance
company really just getting all the data
in one place where we can query it and
make connections between it that makes a
lot of sense for us so that's what we do
we put it all kind of into a central
data link from there though that's you
know most people would say great you
have it all in one place you can analyze
it and the story you know maybe you make
tons of money it's all done it's
wonderful but that's not the case like
do all the analytics that we need to do
all the things that we need to find in
all of our data is a huge amount there's
no way that engineers or even data
scientists can do all the querying and
all the analysis that needs to go into
an actual health insurance company it's
just unfathomable amounts of data and a
huge number of queries and transforms
that we need to do on that
so clover actually trains a large amount
of our insurance operations people
sequel I don't think there's really many
other health care companies that do this
if any but we have probably close to
maybe sorry close to about maybe
somewhere around a hundred people who
actually know sequel that are not
technically trained so they don't come
from a technical background they're not
a data scientist they're not an engineer
they may never have learned a
programming language but we actually
train them in sequel and we actually
train them to build these pipelines so
we have people in insurance operations
they may be in claims they may be in
payment integrity they may be in
provider operations or utilization
management that actually know how to
query a Postgres database so in doing so
what this talk is going to talk a little
bit about today is is kind of the
ramifications for that and how we kind
of control that so obviously that can
lead to a little bit of a wild wild west
scenario where things are kind of people
are just building transforms on a whim
you have a lot of transforms that are
sorry that are just being created kind
of on the fly
and so our talk today we'll talk a
little bit about how we control that and
how we make it easier for people who are
maybe not technically trained to
actually build their own pipelines and
build their own transforms that then can
be run in air flow or other traditional
data processing pipelines so clover has
more than eight hundred different unique
transforms so this isn't just we created
eight hundred transforms in a four loop
these are eight hundred totally
different kinds of transforms they're
almost most of them probably around
ninety percent our sequel transform so
they take a bunch of sequel from a bunch
of different tables and then they
transform that into a new table so like
this is a hypothetical example we get
some membership data and then we get
some claims data we look for claims that
were that happened for dates of service
after a person died so this would be
like a potential fraud or payment
integrity issue and that we shouldn't be
paying for things after someone has died
so clover has more than eight hundred
different kinds of these and most of
them are since equal but we also have
quite a few of them Python and a lot of
them are rich in not by
data scientists or bio engineers but
also by people in insurance operations
so what is that what are kind of some of
the problems that we saw some of these
might be a little obvious but for
starters this doesn't show up so well in
this slide but there are an absolute ton
of prints firms in this picture this is
a picture from an airflow deck and
there's absolutely there's there's
probably a few hundred in this picture
here alone is one of the problems we saw
is that people are just kind of dumping
them into one pipeline people didn't
really build all their transforms
indistinct pipelines like a pipeline for
claims or a pipeline for providers
people were just dumping into this one
massive pipeline and you're not really
building a pipeline but you're creating
a web essentially and that that can lead
to a lot of a lot of probs we also
didn't have really good ways of testing
this you know people are building these
really complex pipelines and you know
how do you actually go about testing
these so those were kind of some of the
problems we saw and we just kind of saw
this this web develop of processes and
tasks and we wanted to kind of make it
easier for people in in data science or
in insurance operations to actually
build more distinct in and better
defined pipelines another problem we saw
is that we were running all this in air
flow so it was really easy to run just a
single task or you can clear out tasks
for those of you familiar with air flow
you can clear out tasks and run the
downstream of them or you can run kind
of the whole pipeline but it's difficult
to run just a section of the pipeline so
with some of our pipelines that are
really huge there are times we want to
rerun just a particular section of the
pipeline or we need to rerun it just
locally for testing and that's pretty
difficult because you have to either set
up air flow or you have to run them
manually just copy the sequel and put it
in a Postgres and that's really really
difficult so enter kind of the clover
transform framework so this is kind of a
little bit of a framework that we
developed around all of our different
transforms that make it easier for
people to build transforms and build
pipelines so what it is is this
basically kind of a wrapper around the
business logic so one of the things that
we saw with some of
Proms is that we had you know kind of
business logic code you know like code
determining like payment integrity or
something like that and we saw that
mixed in with like sorry we saw that
mixed in with like custom monitoring or
we saw people build like you know
special transaction handling in Postgres
or things like that a whole kind of
random collection of weird things and we
thought you know like really we want to
separate the business logic and you know
kind of from the actual infrastructure
from the data infrastructure so that's
what the clever framework does it really
kind of wraps around the transforms that
someone would build kind of wraps around
the sequel or these Python transforms
and then makes it really and then just
kind of abstracts away all the
infrastructure away from from people and
that really makes it easier because if
you're a data scientist or you are an
insurance operations you do not want to
worry about air flow you do not want to
worry about am i monitoring this
correctly do I have the correct
infrastructure to notify people when
something goes wrong that's not
something that most out of scientists
really want to spend time doing so the
clover transform framework is basically
a wrapper around the code and it defines
both the inputs and the outputs and
we'll get to why that's really important
for this so what does this actually look
like so basically we have people writing
a lot of sequel transforms and so what
the transforms actually look like is
there's basically a yellow block at the
top of the sequel which defines what the
transform looks like and that is a
little faint um so but basically it
defines what kind of transform we want
to run in this case it's a let me see if
this laser works
it's a create table as so we're gonna
take this sequel statement here and
actually create a table based on the
sequel statement here we also have
documentation built into it we and we
also define the output and this is
really important for testing so one of
the things that we did that we ran into
before was people would just kind of
build sequel files and tell our flow go
run this but the problem is we really
don't know what the actual inputs to
that file really are and we don't really
know what the outputs to that file are
either and that creates a lot of issues
both from a testing perspective and also
like just understanding what is the
lineage
was very difficult to reason about in
these very large pipelines what is the
lineage of data how does it flow from
you know how does the data flow from one
table to the next to the next to the
next that was very very difficult to
reason about so we defined both the
inputs and the outputs here we also have
documentation built in and the
documentation actually with Python goes
actually into the Postgres database
comments but we have all of that built
into this nice little Amal here and then
we have the sequel at the bottom and so
at the end of the day you just have to
write a select statement it will
actually create the table based on your
select statement it has monitoring
built-in it has documentation built-in
and will actually explain what some of
those features aren't kind of down the
road in this presentation one other
thing we also have is owners of the
transform so we actually define who is
the owner at the company of this
transform so having eight hundred
transforms data science or data
engineering cannot be responsible for
all of them that's obviously
unsustainable so we actually have people
in insurance operations who actually own
the transform so if something goes wrong
they're notified about it they can
adjust business operations if if it's
not something they expected and and that
really ensures that that kind of breaks
down some of the gaps that exist between
engineering and operations that exist in
just about every company so we have a
couple different kinds of transforms I
talked about one earlier which was the
create table as where you just kind of
give it a select statement and it
creates a table in Postgres is that we
also have up cert transforms we also
have just pure sequel or Python
transforms that you can run load
transforms or you can pull a file from
s3 and load that into the database or
vice versa and then of course no ops
where you just want to model the output
of something but you don't actually want
anything to run and that's that's a very
interesting transform as well so what
does this look like under the hood so
under the hood this is a little bit of
code here but this is the create table
as this transform so at the end of the
day the operations person will write
their sequel put the Emma on the top and
then just kind of send it off to be run
but what actually happens under the hood
is we start by creating a transaction
with in Postgres we create this schema
if it doesn't exist we actually start by
creating that
in a swap table so we actually put
underscore swap at the end of it and so
we don't actually affect the regular
production table why we're regenerating
this then we drop if there's been a
previous swap table we create the table
using that sequel we execute it with
explain first and log the explain so
actually in the logs you can see the
explained so if you have an airflow task
that's been running a really long time
and like why is this running so long you
can actually go in and click in the log
and you'll see the explained statement
there and you'll say oh this explain is
really high this is because something
changed and we actually know why then we
add extra so in that
yamo definition they can define foreign
keys they can define indexes we add all
of those for them so they don't ever
have to write you know create index or
create foreign key or handle the naming
conventions that we want for it and then
we also run validation checks and
validation structural checks you can
also define your own in that animal so
people can define their own checks that
if they fail then we roll back the
transaction and then finally we swap the
tables and then we analyze the table at
the end so we do a lot for this for this
particular small little transform which
is pretty much just creating a Postgres
table which is very tiny but all of
these things help to really enforce good
practices all under the hood without you
know insurance operations or data
science from having to to understand all
of that another thing is we we built a
CLI included in this so the graph
structure of it is actually contained
within the transform framework so we
actually have a full CLI that can that
can visualize part of the graph so you
don't have to visualize the whole thing
in airflow or you can use the route
parameter and air flow to look for some
of it but you can actually visualize
just a piece of it you can also run just
a piece of it so this particular command
here will run just this part of the
pipeline and will actually also do
templating so we use Jinja templates and
you can use the start function that
walks you through sorry
that will walk you through basically you
know kind of how to how to set up the
transform so it makes it really really
easy for people to build transform
especially if you're not technically
inclined so that's so it includes a full
CLI and again you can do all of this run
it against you know actually staging
data without ever having to go into air
flow which is a big thing for you know
people for people are in data size for
insurance operations they don't
necessarily want to play with their flow
it can be a little bit of a hassle
sometimes now one of the things we
talked about with is defining the inputs
and the outputs you know why not just
run this transform as is why not just
send it off and and let it be run why do
I have to define the inputs for it and
one of the reasons is is because we
really found out that when you just kind
of send a task off to run even though it
may have unit tests let's say someone
has changed something way upstream in
another task and then that causes the
downstream break so like for example
let's say this task where I here let's
say someone changed this one up here and
it flows through these tasks they work
okay but it causes a break here maybe it
causes a constraint violation or
something typically we would not see
those until they would actually hit
production and that was a really problem
thing because if you have 800 transforms
something's always breaking and that's a
really serious problem
another thing we saw is what happens if
you have two pipelines you know air flow
does a good job of associating DAGs
together in one pipeline but what
happens when pipeline number two here
has dependencies on pipeline number one
how do you actually model that and how
do you actually make sure that if
someone changes the output of pipeline
one that it doesn't break pipeline -
well that's what we did by modeling the
inputs and the outputs of the of the
transform and by having that we can
actually build structural and validation
tests where we can actually run an
integration test automatically for this
particular task where we build the
basically the table for this one and the
table for this one and make sure that
the sequel runs accurately against them
so we can basically ensure that we never
get like a missing column error in arc
in Postgres at all with these transforms
we can pretty much ensure that the
sequel will never have a syntactical
error in production ever that you know
the pipeline's not really going to have
a break in it so it's really about
creating
a very strong validation pipeline and at
the end of the day we do all of this
automatically so if your insurance
operations or data scientist you don't
have to worry about it unless it pops up
a little error saying that you know you
broke downstream pipelines so we also
wanted to build a testing infrastructure
for this the testing is still in Python
though in the future we'll probably
build some input output testing in in
maybe just yamo or just some sort of CSV
files but we also built a testing
framework where you can look at the
upstream tables or the down or the
upstream tables and and pull the
structure from its output create that
structure and then pass in like test
data so if you're testing a transform
and you have to upstream tables that
feed that transform you probably want to
in unit test create those tables and
then feed test data into it normally
that's a lot of setting up you have to
you might create the table and sequel
alchemy models or a couple other ways
and then or just raw sequel and then
pile a whole bunch of data into it
that's a lot of code and that's a lot of
code that's kind of be duplicated so
what we did is created a lot of
boilerplate functions that you just kind
of define the upstream transform from
any different pipeline and then we just
kind of mock it out and pass in the data
one of the other things that we did was
we realized that some of our transforms
are huge they were really really large
and how do you test to transform that as
200 lines long of sequel and that sounds
kind of ridiculous but that is actually
a fair number of our transforms and so
how do you test like an individual
component of it to make sure the logic
actually works and so one of the things
that we developed which is actually open
source now and you can go find it is
called PG mock it's in Clover halls
public github and basically allows you
to take out sections of the sequel and
test them so actually in this particular
case what we do is we have a sub quarry
here and we say we don't really care
about testing that sub quarry we just
want to test maybe this select up here
and so we can actually sub out we can
use this little package actually sub out
pieces of sequel with test data so here
we sub it out with you know just kind of
like these random high values here
and then we can just test this sequel as
is and it's it's great for testing sorry
it's great for testing large pieces of
sequel so and this is totally open
source so you can find this today and
it's a really nice package for testing
large sequel any questions I know I've
just kind of flown through all of that
any questions we call one in the back
yeah
mmm-hmm any sort of like query from
other pipelines that might be upstream
is that all tested locally or yes okay
it's actually tested in the unit tests
we have continuous integration that will
test it to so if you you know you cannot
push it to master until that is tested
in the continuous integration and the
continuous integration will test that
you're not breaking those pipelines so
there's also a local Postgres individual
contributors okay so we actually each
one of these transforms is run sorry is
run in a post quest transaction yeah and
we actually create the upstream tables
and down or the upstream tables in that
transaction and then run the transform
and then close that transaction sorry
and close that transaction and delete it
and we do that for every single one of
these more than 800 transforms are there
like other background processes for like
syncing the individuals local Postgres
with what is improving
we can do that because we are a
healthcare company we don't like to put
too much pH I on someone's local machine
yeah so we don't want to put a whole
bunch of you know patient medical
records on your helical machine one of
the things that clover also has found is
while unit tests are good with a lot of
our data pipelines you really do need to
test it with a copy of production data
to really make sure that it's doing what
you think it's gonna do it's really hard
to do just pure unit tests other than
testing basic logic so if you really
want to we try not to have people
actually run it in to actually pull down
it down locally however in this previous
one I talked about the run here you can
actually specify a staging database here
and it will run against a copy of
production data in staging from your
local machine basically so you can call
it flow from locally thank you
one more yeah I have a question so how
do we ensure that person a and B are not
run in the same queries or quaintness
same tables how do we ensure that the
person name or no person a and person B
are not run in the same queries or away
in the same tables at the same time kind
of like that at the same time or I mean
they see something that runs from the
daily basis
yeah so all of these go into pipelines
and air flow so air flow kind of
controls and we only let it run at a
certain amount of time within our flow
as far as running it locally how do we
make sure two people aren't running it
at the same time we basically just use
staging databases for that so it doesn't
actually hit production with most of
these transforms if two people do run at
the same time you will get various
locking errors I think my question was
more of two people were at the same
table so you guys don't care that
multiple people can create the same
table and I mean how do we do access
control is that kind of yes
yeah so as far as access control it's a
little bit of a different system for the
most part we've built access control
into Postgres users that limit who can
access the table at what time and we
actually have a whole different package
that I could talk about that limits
access control to the database and
limits who can touch what and when and
that's all of course being a healthcare
company where your project just just to
clarify what was a question about like
deduplication like two to two different
people run the same kind of query and
create two tables which which
essentially have the same data oh I see
what you mean how do we i see the
deduplication there that's a problem
that we have not totally solved um we
I'll talk about it a little bit in the
future how we're handling
discoverability but certainly we do have
people creating tables that are a little
bit similar from one another and
probably could be just one table it is a
problem that we have for sure yeah
but we'll talk a little bit about how we
kind of try to prevent that in the next
slide actually so one of the things we
have with this as well though is
monitoring built in so one of the things
is we we use data dog for monitoring for
keeping track of like the row counts for
keeping track of the number of
completeness of a certain column how
many null values are in a column and all
of that can actually be defined in the
UM
so someone who's in insurance operations
or data science can easily just define
this in the amo
it goes to data dog they don't more have
to worry about any of the back-end
infrastructure and we can use things
like anomaly tracking and data dog to
know when something goes amiss so this
is a particular pipeline that got
overrun and airflow actually and so it's
normal daily snapshot count was here and
then all the sudden it jumped up really
high and so we can keep track of of
basically when things go amiss and so
this is uh this is one really nice
feature and again it all happens in the
back end and you don't have to worry
about building any of that out for your
transforms so going to your question
there about the deduplication well you
have eight hundred transforms how do
people find out what these transforms do
how do they find out like I have all
maybe there's already a transform that
does what I wanted to do how do I find
out about this well because we define
the inputs and outputs we can actually
build full graphs of the lineage and
we've actually done that in an
application that we call data Bodega and
this is an internal application to
clover health and it allows you to
search and document any sort of table
within our system as well as who is
querying it whose coin did in mode
analytics and also see the lineage of it
so like this particular table has one
upstream
table that is derived from and then it's
used in these downstream tables here and
so we have this whole application this
whole website that's built around that
that shows the lineage it also has all
sorts of documentation some of that
documentation comes from the yam l
definition itself others of it people
can just type in and write themselves we
have links to various documentation so
kind of the roundabout answer and strain
of your question is that you know how do
I find something like how do we avoid
duplication is basically we created this
application that people can more easily
find tables and find pieces of data that
they can use in their various day-to-day
operations and things like that yeah
question
yeah
the question was you know like is this
only things that happen within this
framework there are a few things for the
most part it is with things that are
within this framework which is pretty
much most things that are at Clover but
it does have some things outside of it
as well
it also has a report so we used mode
analytics to to do a lot of reporting
and we keep track of the lineage between
these tables and mode analytics as well
so that's also included here yeah so
another thing that we built on top of
this is we have a couple different types
of transforms we also have machine
learning built on top of this so one of
the things is you know machine learning
has lots of infrastructure that goes
behind this and both Amazon and Google
have tried to you know build systems
that make it easier for people to not
have to touch the infrastructure for
machine learning clover has actually
built this into our transform framework
so if you're someone who's in data
science and you're like well you know I
really don't want to have to build all
the second learn models and build the
infrastructure for it you can actually
just use this yellow definition which
will take input data sets it will split
up the data set in this case into
training and validation and testing
splits it also you know has different
features that you can put into it and it
can run most of the second learn
classifiers and algorithms in there and
you can specify parameters in it and
again it's all done via this nice little
llamó config so you can really easily
try out different machine learning
things you can really discover things
that you know you might not think
machine learning would be good at but
actually is and so we've done that with
a number of healthcare things and and
it's working out really quite well and
it's very accessible to someone who's
not you know really heavily trained up
in the ml side yeah question of the
keynote what one-hot encode
that's this so typical machine learning
transfer yeah I'm not as today on some
of those ml thanks but I don't know the
answer that so I I could probably find
out for you but yeah this this is this
is what we use for most ml so but I did
sorry I don't know totally the question
for that so so that's pretty much the
end of it we'll open it up to more
questions now but before I do so of
course I have to give this pitch clover
is hiring engineers and data scientists
really aggressively I shouldn't say
aggressively but really passionately we
are trying to basically double the size
of our teams so we're trying to go from
like 50 engineers up to like 100 so if
you if you haven't talked to one of our
recruiters you definitely should clover
is a really great company we do so many
different things with data we solve some
really unique challenges that I haven't
seen it any other company we do
everything from ml the data pipelines
data science we do so many different
things we're a company that we're really
tackling one of the country's biggest
problems you know how do we you know
tackle healthcare make people healthier
and reduce costs at the same time it
really is one of the biggest challenges
and in this country this day we we have
a team that really values diversity at
Clover and it's a really passionate
environment I think everybody really
wants to work there and really wants to
make people's lives better so so yeah so
if you're interested come see me on
office hours
clover health.com slash careers or
anyone with a clover health batch so go
back to questions and anything else yeah
I was just kind of curious for the some
of the m/l yam will subside anywhere you
are I'm right here for some of the like
MMO stuff you guys are doing what so
what does the workflow look like for
someone who wants to use machine
learning them in that case so like what
what what's their start and then how do
they know how well their model didn't
yeah so we do have a lot of monitoring
around the models as well I have to
plead the fifth a little bit on this
because I don't totally know the ml side
we haven't we there's definitely
engineers who could answer that much
better than I can but we do put a lot of
training tour our machine learning that
was one thing why the machine learning
team picked clever trends from a
framework to build on top of is because
we could build all that underneath I
think they they were worried that people
would build kind of machine learning
models without you know without actually
doing any monitoring or actually
monitoring how your feature sets change
over time or anything like that and so
that's one of the reasons they built on
top of this is we could put monitoring
right into it but I can't answer
specifically I don't have the specifics
on that unfortunately hi how did you
structure your training program for the
operations folks and how did you deal
with like obvious resistance you would
get from right yeah that's very
interesting so I I wouldn't say there
was actually huge resistance to it the
one interesting thing about operations
with healthcare is a lot of them are
just craving more data you know they
kind of see you know they have all the
sudden like I just want to know you know
like did this member have this happen on
this day or you know is there situations
you know happening in this particular
with this provider that might be you
know considered wasteful so they're
really craving data so when we started
giving them the tools to do this it's
actually still kind of an opt-in program
sorry oh it's still an opt-in program
and a lot of them continue to opt into
it so it's something that most of them
really want to improve their skills and
want to have these skills to really make
better decisions in their day to day
operations the actual program is is
actually divided up into a couple
different classes that you take and they
go all the way from kind of you know
basic sequel all the way up to like
really advanced sequel building and even
some Python as well and it also ties in
with our parsing framework which I
talked about at dead engine complex sure
so yes I don't want the microphone
do you have a review process for adding
transforms to the framework and how do
operations folks yeah handle that yeah
we do have a review we generally ask for
a data scientist or data engineer to
review it it depends on actually the
transfer himself there are certain ones
that that's just kind of our ad hoc and
show up kind of out of nowhere and those
we don't review as well but typically
there is kind of a I guess you could say
a lifecycle of the transform so they
start off kind of ad hoc and then they
kind of move into a you know a little
bit more finished models where you know
a data scientist might help insurance
operations build a better model and then
for some of them like claims or
providers there's actually an engineer
who is built out a full model for that
so there's kind of a lifecycle of which
it goes through so it kind of depends on
what stage in the lifecycle that's in
that depends how much review it gets is
that enough data cancer if give pays for
the reviews yeah yeah we do it all kit
based I you maintain your framework
supports updates right I up sirs yeah
up so how do you avoid that look like
someone is trying to do a create table
so we do require that for the most part
in that one we do require to be one
transform one output there are
exceptions to that we don't hard and
force that for the most part we just
default to it being it needs to be
upstream or downstream so the two tasks
cannot be parallel they need to be
upstream or downstream of one another so
whenever someone writes an update you
want it to mention the dependencies to
it yeah correct all these you have to
basically you have to define all the
inputs you can't just like let's say you
create a table that selects all from my
table you have to define that as the
input and if you don't this validation
system will actually fail so if you
forget to put an input it will alert you
yeah any more questions okay let's list
the last question and before that I I
want to remind how you know the
speaker's value your feedback so please
go and pick one of those cards and
tell tell us and the speaker is how
they're doing and then there's their
office hours right after to talk you're
gonna be in the office hours right so so
you're welcome to continue asking
questions and the last thing
thanks for silencing your cellphone's
the downside is that people tend to
forget about them so what would somebody
forgot a cell phone and if if you are
such a person just just go to a
registration they have some maybe the
heavy phone so one more right here
hi so this goes a bit in the direction
of good questions like how do you ensure
that data policies like privacy policies
are being met or if you have like a one
big data like instead of it's definitely
a challenge I contact about a little
before we have another framework called
clover DB that actually restricts access
depending on different access levels to
people so there's different kind of
levels of access that you can be in so
right yeah you may not be able to
actually join those two tables for the
most part this runs in production so you
so you are able to make the transform
that makes those joins you may not be
able to see that data depending on your
level of of Claire of your level in the
hierarchy that you are
you